Film Courage: How do you get to a character's
emotional truth? Dui Jarrod, Writer/Director: As a writer I used to
really struggle with finding characters
emotional truths and the reason why that
was is because I had not found my
emotional truth when you're in the
hamster wheel of trying to make content
and all you're doing is creating and
you're not living it's hard for you to
really connect to yourself and so after
I got to New York and I really kind of
started to settle my life I started to
travel a lot more and make sure that I
started to have experiences and I
started to engage in my own personal
growth and so then when I found my own
personal growth and who I was I was able
to in an interesting way tap into that
emotional truth for a character and that
there motional truth for me is defined
as what the character wants to truly
believe about himself but nothing in the
world is saying this as such so for
instance a young filmmaker who really
wants to be a filmmaker but their
universe is telling them that you're not
a filmmaker that is their emotional
truth that they want to do a filmmaker
and I think the journey of a story
whether it's a short story or a film or
a play it's how to get that character to
believe in the truth that's already
beating in their heart so that's how I
think that you get to a character's
emotional truth is to find out what it
is inside of them that really gets their
blood moving that gets their heart rate
up that gets them gives them purpose to
get out of the bed that is what their
emotional truth is so the world is
telling them there's one thing but
that's not what they feel inside it's
not what they feel inside and for many
of us that's that's the reality you know
we're like wanting to build this
business but the world is saying you
don't have the credit score or you're in
the wrong City to do that or you're not
capable of doing it and being you to be
able to overcome all of those eyes to
get what you feel that you're supposed
to have is where I think the story
really is but there are certain films
that really hit home for you they do not
one of them one of the stories I think
is moonlight that does that beautifully
because his ultimate emotional truth is
he deserved to be loved
that he was worthy of love and belonging
and where he was gonna get that black
didn't know you know he just didn't know
where he was gonna get that from and
being you see especially when he gets to
the third act he's so calcified from the
world that he has quarantined himself
off all he does is work out and he does
all these drug deals in order to make
money again a very dangerous way to
exist because he had come through the
prison system but then when he meets up
with the guy at the very end and he
starts to break down that you are worthy
of love because he saw somebody cooked
for him in a very loving way he saw
somebody have a conversation with you
know so I love moonlight as one of the
greatest examples of a character finding
area most of the truth even if it was
just subtle in that at the very you know
what about a play yeah so my favorite
play that illustrates emotional truth
would probably be the mountaintop by
Katori Hall she did a play that's about
Martin Luther King and Khmer which is a
woman who was working in the hotel that
he was staying in this is the night
before his murder and so the emotional
truth that Monday the King was trying to
come to in that pieces I'm prepared to
die like I'm ready for this death but
again the when he shows up into this
hotel room this woman is talking how
much he's needed how much he's leading
these organizations and how much how
important he is to the movement which
tells him that he's not necessarily done
here so to see that exploration in the
course of that which was a two-hour
two-person play which was phenomenal
again was another way of me being able
to see how someone kids to their
emotional truth that was totally
different from the way that it was done
and like moonlight and sorry it is based
on a real life character Marv Luther
King yeah but I did ya know so she's
totally fictionalized it's a
fictionalized example of what he
experienced the night before and it is a
stellar piece of theater interesting it
is stellar yeah
so he knew he knew it was coming because
the COINTELPRO and all the different
things though I think you always known I
think you always know I think you know
when the Sun move on I think you know
when it's time to stay I think you know
when it's time to deal with something
that you don't need to really want to
deal with I think the universe always
tells you those messages in no science
or you know under the Kings case when it
was signed for him tonight I think he
knew I think we always know
you